[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti
Sono molto soddisfatta finalmente di
fare un tetto Talk Perché ne avrò
ascoltati un centinaio anche di più da
quando ho scoperto che cosa sono l'ho
scoperto guardando le serie americane
ovviamente
e quando ho visto che iniziavano a farli
in Italia mi chiedevo Ma come si fa a
partecipare come posso fare quindi
quando è arrivata la telefonata non ho
fatto neanche finire la domanda Avevo
già risposto Sì vengo venendo qua ho
scoperto che ci sono persone che hanno
già fatto tre quattro tette Quindi
adesso sono già in frigo la perché devo
riuscire a farne assolutamente altri
questo perché il capricorno è un po'
così mai soddisfatto
prospettive prospettive una bellissima
una bellissima definizione che però vuol
dire tutto non vuol dire niente quindi
dopo aver pensato tanto tanto a cosa
potervi raccontare cosa potervi lasciare
ho deciso di prendere il mio esempio
perché
Perché vedo tante mie amiche mamme io
per tornare al Talk di stamattina non
sono mamma E ormai quello che hai fatto
è fatto quindi
appartengo alla faccio parte di quel
disastro dell'Italia
tante mamme mie amiche Sono disperate
Perché i figli sono stati rimandati sono
stati bocciati non hanno voglia di
studiare e la mia risposta Allora è
sempre Vi ricordate come ero io a scuola
ecco io non ho mai amato studiare non ho
mai amato seguire le lezioni o meglio
seguire lezioni noiose non ho mai
imparato non ho mai amato leggere libri
e imparare a memoria quello che capivo a
lezione lo mettevo in pratica Ma se
dovevo mettermi a casa a leggere il
libro e ripetere Non c'era verso non ce
la facevo questo fa parte del mio
carattere ma fino a un certo punto della
mia vita questo mi è stato fatto notare
e pesare come un come mancanza di voglia
Come non riuscirai mai a combinare
niente nella vita perché vai male a
scuola Oddio male ero sempre nella
fascia media del è intelligente ma non
si applica
Questa è la storia della mia vita però
ero sempre invece tra i primi quando
c'era da far casino quando c'era da
organizzare scherzi feste lì ero sempre
molto molto brava
e io ho sempre pensato ma cosa combinerò
mai nella vita visto che non mi piace
studiare e mi hanno sempre detto che se
non ti piace studiare non farai mai
successo non farai mai carriera non
troverai mai un lavoro
e quindi chi sono io sono Elisa
Guarnieri founder founder di cosa di me
stessa perché mi sono creata io perché
nessuno Nessuno delle persone che mi
hanno accompagnato dall'epoca della
scuola all'epoca fino all'epoca
dell'università nessuno avrebbe
scommesso un euro su di me perché perché
non avevo una
missione non avevo non avevo
quella quel fuoco dentro che mi batteva
per una materia perché non eccellevo
E io invece mi sono inventata una strada
mi sono inventata un lavoro una
professione che ha anche neanche portato
nel mio al successo e come ho fatto
vi faccio vedere la mia Timeline della
mia vita perché è costellata di per caso
nel 1994 mi iscrivo a economia e
commercio per caso Perché in realtà
volevo fare la giornalista sportiva
essendo io appassionata di sport ma
anche lì fisico Atletico alta
muscolosa puoi fare tutti gli sport che
vuoi poi eccellere non eccellevo in
nessuno sport i miei genitori hanno
provato a farmi qualsiasi sport a farmi
fare ma a me non piaceva faticare non mi
piaceva la competizione non mi
interessava arrivare prima e quindi
tutto questo fisico tutto questo
potenziale talento buttato alle ortiche
quindi non mi piaceva correre Ho giocato
dieci anni a basket giocava a basket per
stare con le mie amiche e divertirmi a
me del basket non mi interessava niente
Non se mi chiedete adesso In che
campionato giocavi non lo so So che
andavo a fare le partite nel weekend ma
non so il perché In che campionato
giocavamo ero la più alta ero la più
scarsa non mi piaceva correre continuava
a insaccarmi tutte le dita a farmi male
quindi questo è mi scrive con i miei
Commercio perché perché dico facciamolo
il giornalista sportiva perché in realtà
mi piace seguire lo sport mi piace
capire cosa ci sta dietro allo sport
cerco di entrare nelle facoltà di
scienze della comunicazione che nel 1994
in Italia erano solo quattro Di cui una
a Bologna
di cui diretta da Umberto Eco quindi
cose un po' bassa ma ovviamente non
passo il test Ci mancherebbe cioè
eravamo in 2.500 per 200 posti non ero
certo io quella che poteva passare il
test
quindi mi presento allo sportello di
Economia e Commercio di Parma che è
l'università più vicina dove abito io
che la provincia di Piacenza e dico Sono
venuta a prendere un po' di informazioni
a capire quando chiudono le iscrizioni
domani allora mi iscrivo Ecco
così ho scelto proprio coscientemente
con i miei Commercio il mio piano di
studi è stato un piano di studi
compilato alla cieca perché non sapevo
cosa fosse il marketing non avevo idea
di cosa volesse dire ho scelto
pubblicità perché dico sarà una cosa
interessante il corso in pubblicità e ho
scelto altri
personaggi perché mi piacevano i titoli
al un percorso di studi
l'università è stato un disastro il mio
libretto di il mio libretto degli esami
andava dal 30 e lode in Economia e
tecnica dei trasporti Non chiedetemi
perché al 19 di statistica 2
Quindi avevo la media del 24 precisa
perfetta
e quindi anche lì i miei genitori
disperati se mi hai già detto io ho
passato una villa vita con genitori
incazzati neri con me perché non davo
soddisfazioni a scuola e loro mi
dicevano Questo è il tuo lavoro e tu lo
stai facendo male
una mattina Appunto
Invece di studiare ero alla scrivania
nella mia cameretta e sfogliavo un
giornale di moda e vedo che negli
indirizzi in fondo dei Brand che erano
stati usati nei servizi fotografici vedo
Nike Nike Reggio Emilia
e dico come Nike Reggio Emilia e Reggio
Emilia faccio la tesi sulla Nike è a
Reggio Emilia vado là qualcuno mi darà
un po' di informazioni e così per caso
decido di fare la tesi sulla Nike grazie
alla tesi entro a fare uno stage in Nike
nel 2000 perché Perché L'università mi
chiami e mi dice Nike Cerca uno stagista
nel dipartimento pr e io dico ma le pr
sono quelle delle discoteche
cioè nei miei libri
dell'università di marketing e di
pubblicità Pubbliche Relazioni era un
paragrafetto così ufficio stampa era una
riga cioè dico ma le pietre cosa sono
Vabbè vado a fare il colloquio e trovo
una persona che in realtà forse una
delle poche la prima persona vede
Qualcosa in me Quindi nonostante io mi
sia seduta a dire Guarda io non so
veramente niente eh Cioè ma davvero non
so niente non mi importa io ho bisogno
di qualcuno che mi aiuti che venga qui
che mi aiuti
morale entro in Nike e da lì la mia vita
cambia perché lì scopro un lavoro li
scopro Qual è la mia vocazione scopro
Qual è la mia passione che è raccontare
storie parlare di sport stare a contatto
con gli atleti partecipare agli eventi
organizzare gli eventi stare dentro alla
macchina
Nel 2020 poi succede quello che sappiamo
tutti la pandemia Io ormai erano
vent'anni che facevo la consulente per
Nike Ah altra cosa io non ho mai avuto
un contratto a tempo indeterminato e
anche quando me l'hanno offerto l'ho
sempre rifiutato sono sempre stata una
partita IVA dall'inizio dall'inizio per
necessità perché ti assumevano e ti
dicevano no ma questi contratti di Coco
coma e come se fossi Assunta e tu non
capivi bene la dopo il cococò per una
serie di vicende ho aperto la partita
IVA e da lì non ho più voluto essere
ingabbiata in una contratto a tempo
indeterminato
erano ormai vent'anni che facevo la
consulente per Nike Ma in quei vent'anni
avevo sviluppato anche tantissimi
contatti avevo anche iniziato a fare la
manager sportiva per tantissimi atleti
nella Coppa del Mondo di sci nel mondo
del nuoto nel NBA tantissime cose ma mi
sentivo appesantita sentivo che non ero
felice però pensavo fosse la normalità
la vita è questa se vuoi lavorare è così
la mattina ti svegli incazzato devi
andare a lavorare e basta e te la tieni
invece arriva lockdown e scopro che
facendo un passo indietro rallentando
uscendo da una ruota tipo criceto cioè
scopro un mondo scopro che io stavo
vivendo dentro un tunnel che mi sembrava
la realtà perché non avevo cambiato la
prospettiva
scopro che invece c'è un mondo fuori c'è
un cielo azzurro C'è l'umanità
e quindi decido di lasciare quello che
stavo facendo una parte perché gli
atleti sono rimasti la gestione degli
Atleti mi è rimasta Perché proprio nel
mio nel mio DNA e inizia a fare un altro
tipo di percorso mi avvicino allo yoga e
la meditazione e poi dico senti in
questi vent'anni io un po' di conoscenza
un po' di contatti qualcosa avrò fatto
qualcuno mi cercherà
cosa faccio io nella vita qual è il mio
lavoro cosa mi sono inventata io mi sono
inventato un lavoro che si chiama
Pubbliche Relazioni ufficio stampa
strategie di comunicazione In realtà io
cosa faccio io creo connessioni Io
capisco avendo una mente elastica Ma
questo non lo so perché me lo dico io
l'ho scoperto con anni di psicoterapia
quando pensavo di non valere niente
invece la psicologa mi ha detto No
guarda che tu hai una mente molto
elastica un'intelligenza emotiva
In effetti creo connessioni Cioè capisco
quali sono le persone che possono
entrare in contatto per creare qualcosa
di bello suggerisco punti di vista
perché non ce n'è solo uno Molte volte i
clienti vedono solo un punto di vista
solo il loro prodotto io dico ma non
guardiamo il tuo prodotto guardiamo al
valore ai messaggi a quello che c'è
intorno Facciamo che le persone si
avvicinano al tuo prodotto per quello
che loro stanno cercando per i valori
per i messaggi che stanno cercando
racconto storie perché io anche
lavorando con gli atleti io se lavoro
con un giocatore di basket non devo
raccontare come gioca a basket lo vedono
tutti se io devo raccontare un giocatore
di calcio non devo raccontare come gioca
a calcio lo sanno già tutti come gioca a
calcio Io devo farlo conoscere al di
fuori devo trovare devo cambiare
prospettiva devo cambiare punto di vista
devo far conoscere quello che la gente
ancora non conosce e risolvo problemi
problemi che con il social come sapete
sono molto diffusi
una storia di Instagram postata male
postata per sbaglio
che rovina la reputazione la telefonata
di notte e mi dice Oddio ho fatto questa
cosa Ora come rimedio io rimedio
o almeno ci provo
e quindi oggi io di cosa mi occupo mi
occupo di sport mi occupo di food e mi
occupo di Wine pur non sapendo niente di
tutti e tre nel senso verticale perché
Sport Sì ne so parlare ma andare a
vedere le partite mediamente mi annoio
mi piace tutto quello che c'è dietro mi
piace conoscere gli atleti mi piace
sapere raccontare le storie Food lavoro
con uno chef giapponese Io odio la
cucina giapponese non so usare le
bacchette non ho mai mai mai gradito
andare al giapponese ma lui mi ha fatto
conoscere un aspetto che io non
conoscevo del Giappone ha delle idee a
Un pensiero ed è quello che mi piace far
conoscere agli altri
Wine lavoro per una cantina di vini
anche molto famosa siciliana
da circa due anni Io sono praticamente
astemia
quando ho fatto il colloquio con la
signora ho detto se bevo ma non sono in
realtà niente
Cioè io al massimo riesco avere tre
sorsi di rosè di bianco il rosso non
riesco e la mia prima volta al Vinitaly
io ero esattamente come se mi portasse a
una fiera di idraulica
io mi aggiravo così
bello belli li stand Beh tutto bianco
Cioè l'inutilità mi sento inutile quella
fiera è questo
Ma come vi dicevo la cosa importante in
tutto è sempre le storie e i valori e i
messaggi di qualsiasi cosa di qualsiasi
cosa voi dovete parlare dovete
raccontare vi dovete approcciare non
fermatevi mai a guardare solo la forma
Ma guardate a quello che vi sto
raccontando
Quindi con cosa vi lascio con un
consiglio ascoltate il vostro istinto
perché generalmente il vostro istinto vi
porta dalla parte giusta non tradite mai
voi stessi non fate mai qualcosa per far
piacere agli altri fate quello per cui
sentite di essere portati fate quello
che la vostra etica vi dice di fare e
cercate sempre una discomfort zone state
sempre cercate sempre Scegliete la parte
più scomoda di dove vi trovate perché è
lì che riuscirete a trovare la vostra
strada Grazie
[Applauso]